What's up everyone?
Today we are learning english with the
highly successful british band Coldplay
they have so many great
hits that it was really
hard to choose just a few for today's
lesson andif you watch until
the end you will also learn
with a fun interview that Chrisand
Johnny did on the Ellen show!
I think we dreamed big without thinking
it might be possible right so
when I said that I'm sure I
half felt it but also thought it was
I was saying something ridiculous.
Do you want to understand
natives even when we speak fast
without getting lost, without missing
the jokes and without subtitles?
Just like Hassan who says that watching
our channel in the last four months
is working like magic so
if that sounds good to you
don't forget to hit that
subscribe button and the bell
down below so that you don't
miss any of our new lessons.
Do you find it difficult to
understand fast speaking natives?
Then I highly recommend our
Fluent with Friends course.
In this 48 week course you will learn
with the first two seasons of Friends,
you'll receive PDF power lessons every
week, vocabulary memorization software
access to our Fluency Circle global
community and so much more and did
you know you can try it right now for
free with our three-part Masterclass!
All you have to do is click up
here or down in the description
below to learn more and sign up
now we hope to see you there.
If you're enjoying this lesson
then i highly recommend that you
check out our music lesson playlist
where you'll find a whole range of
lessons from Queen to Lady Gaga
all you have to do is click up
here or down in the description
below to choose your next lesson.